[Music]
the people here have had enough
all of these guys have lost their sons
we don't want any more sons dying on our
streets ladies and gents
they're sick of the bloodshed the young
lives lost
ladies and gents let's do this together
young people have to see that we're
standing together we need the mothers to
stop the narrative that there's no men
in our communities there are men in our
communities there are men that want to
stop the knife crime and we're going to
be faithful we're going to be diligent
and we're going to do it
they march through their own streets
demanding change
side by side with the families of the
victims
can you try and put into words how this
tragedy has affected your family well
except for all of us me
my misses you know we're home
and he's like we don't even have a life
you know every time we woke up because
germany was our our life he was
everything to us you know
i lose my son and the guy that killed my
son he loses his life as well he's in
prison you know it's real it's really
sad for us to live be living like that
you know very very sad i'm so so sorry
for you
all right ladies and gents for those who
don't know this is the spot where
jermaine calls was sadly taken from us
i saw bishop grandison here do you mind
saying a prayer for the family
god we pray for peace on our streets
we come against the violence the
bloodshed
father of god we
we cry out to you god as a community we
will group together father god to fight
this epidemic this disease has come
[Music]
anthony if i could just continue um why
do you think young children are picking
up knives they're picking up knives
because a lot of the young children are
claiming they're claiming that they
don't feel safe
it's best that you stop and search your
child
before they met have to do so and i'm
standing here publicly to tell people
i'm working with the met
look at my skin color i'll stand with
the met until we get this problem dealt
last year there was a record 30 teenage
murders in london
five of those happened here in croydon
more than any other part of the capital
but the killings have inspired the birth
of a new movement
this community is uniting
there's a sense of hope
i love freud and i like
what's
a lot of people trying to do
and i'm trying to make change
troy davis runs a mentoring service for
young people in the area
why do you think
there was that level of violence last
year if you're not giving these young
children hope
then what's going to happen it's it's
going to spiral out of control so what
we are trying to do is to ensure that we
give these children an opportunity and
again making sure that they progress in
society we never use that cart mentality
you know take the tea off you can you
just keep pushing you have to keep
pushing you know if we have a defeatist
attitude in anything that we do then
nothing changes so it's important for us
to continue to progress if you have a
child you know if they if they struggle
you don't give up on that child so you
don't give up on any children as far as
they're concerned they're all our
children
ready
this is how jj chooses to fight knife
crime
he's mentoring a young man who's trying
to leave a life of violence on the
streets
and jj has a past of his own because
i've gone through those stuff myself it
makes it much more easier for me to
engage with them because they prefer to
engage with someone like me that they've
known that's gone to prison come out
made a change and all these things and
looking to make a difference in their
life it's nicer
where there's poverty and
stuff like that i think there's
motivation for people to kind of want to
you know walk up and down with knives
and stuff like that but what i look at
there is so much
talent that we don't speak about
does that annoy you that that good work
gets overshadowed by the bad headlines
by the knife crime by the murders
definitely 100 it does 100 it does
because all the good work that you've
done with all the children it gets
snowfalled with oh um someone just been
stabbed down there and killed but the
child that's actually done an
apprenticeship or gone through some kind
of academic to be successful past their
masters and got all of that stuff done
the bad stuff will take precedence over
that how long have you been boxing for
um
five six years munir says he may not be
alive today if it wasn't for jj
hearing his side of the story
you know made me change a lot because
he's been through it as well yeah that
helped me as well get you know better in
every way and you know just focus on
myself and my future and everything i
just look forward because trust me this
being on the street and everything
because
it makes no sense
what is it like living that life on the
street it must be uh must be terrifying
at times
to be honest earth is is terrifying
because you never know what can happen
you can be at a wrong time wrong moment
wrong arrow
and you know you can easily anything can
happen you know so
it's terrifying and you know
i just want
every youth to actually just you know
take up a moment for themselves and just
think like
what i might actually do with my life
and i can make it better
but what is the reason for all the
violence last year
i've come to meet a recently retired
murder detective who investigated
several of the teenage murders here
social media has grown as we know so
much over the last
10 15 years and there's a lot of
unpleasant things between
young people on on those sites and it
escalates so quickly there is always
more that can be done
you've seen what positivity emanates
from the the boys over in croydon and
what they want to do to target and
really help youngsters get
uh away from this kind of arena of the
thought that violence is the way to deal
with certain situations
what's it like i mean it must take
extraordinary courage to knock on the
door of a mother to tell her that their
teenage son has been has been killed
it's it's definitely the part of a
police officer's role part of their job
that they
they dread you know i've done it many
times it's very emotional as you can
imagine and the waves that go out of
that it's not just a family it's all
about friends schools
everybody's affected by it
i've been invited to meet someone who's
grieving the loss of their younger
brother
do you think that these young kids have
any idea of the impact that their
actions are having
not at all
not absolutely no
[Music]
jermaine guppel was just 14 when he was
stabbed just streets away from his home
a lot of people do ask me do you think
they meant to kill your brother
they knew what they were doing when they
carried a knife but i don't believe that
they meant to kill him
but they don't understand the impact of
carrying a knife
any any small severity of the artery
will kill a young person my brother was
stabbed in his leg so we have to provide
the education to these young people
around impact around why they shouldn't
carry a knife not just tell them they
shouldn't but why they shouldn't so what
i'm doing now i've actually set up a
foundation called the jfj foundation jfj
stands for justice for germaine and it
isn't just the justice where you know
people been sentenced and put away the
justice is making sure that our young
people are living and breathing out here
being able to fulfill their futures in
what they wanted to do like what my
brother wanted to do
and what about you do you have any kids
no i don't have any kids i'm scared to
have kids i'm really traumatized by my
brother's death that i'm wondering
whether
kids is the right option right now
because it's the impact that it's had on
me but then at the same time i'm
wondering if i have a child
is my child going to get stabbed
is my child am i going to have to go
through that trauma again
because of what's happening now
and the amount of teenagers that are
dying am i going to have to raise a
child only to know later on in it and
their life that they're going to get
killed
and that's the trauma i don't want can
you put your hands together
young man is going to say a prayer for
young people in croydon thank you
amen
you know what standing here especially
as a young person in ministry
and it really breaks my heart the fact
that you know young people are still
killing young people
you know and i really believe that with
the power of god and and with us
standing together it doesn't matter
whether you're christian you're muslim
whatever faith you are but if we come
together a change will happen
and father god we pray lord jesus that
every bloodshed that's happened in the
past lord father we pray that it will
happen no more we pray of our god that
not only in croydon while we're speaking
to lambeth we're speaking to southern
we're going all over the uk lord father
god that the bloodshed will stop